[Music]
one of the
benefits of doing this show is i get to
meet and chat with
people who i've whose work i've enjoyed
for as many years as i've enjoyed the
work
of this next guest his new movie white
bird in a blizzard in theaters october
24th christopher maloney good to see you
sir
good to see you here thanks for coming
on this program my pleasure yeah i mean
i've
enjoyed watching you for i go back to
the oz days
yeah well when you were on oz yeah
disturbing television well
i used to watch my wife and i would
watch oz together
it could be a strong marriage you know
what let's say it could be
the show that my wife and i have watched
together that's led to the most awkward
silences or
actually i was i was gonna thought you
were gonna go with the most intense
cuddling yeah because it can
scare the hell out of people what was it
like for you when you were
when you got a script and you knew what
you had to do on the show and things
were going to happen where you
it would be something like this you know
read read read flip flip flip
and you get to the part and you go
wow that's who i am that's who you are
that's
that's how i'm gonna play it right and
your character was uh something else
yeah say the least where you went from
thinking you were the devil and then
that you had some sort of heart of gold
but still beat somewhere inside yeah
and then you i mean you nailed it you
know that was a great great role and
enjoyed your your work in law and order
for so many years as well
um so what is more brutal uh uh
being being being in the uh
the oz the oz penitentiary yes or going
through a one in five start
with your washington redskins this year
you know i'd even have to stretch it out
just um just to be a redskins fan
in the past two decades it's been it's
been a rough
post joe gibbs has been a tough one
right tough roller coaster but in the
last
two decades and includes the return of
joe gibbs right i mean yeah but you know
i even when that happened i just thought
from everything i've seen being a pro
coach
you know you get your shot and
well i think once you've hit the reach
the top of your
career you're the you you've won the
super bowl not once twice you know three
times for him
sure where is there to go i just i just
don't think you have
uh i think ages against you i think i i
think you need you know the guts and the
fire in the belly i don't think you can
artificially manufacture it i think you
have to have that sense of desperation
of
i need to make a name for myself and i
need to implement my plans and my ideas
and
where do you stand on rg3 do you like
him do you i mean he was a savior two
years ago he hasn't been able to stay on
the field what are your
my feelings were i thought the offense
they had in place for him
was brilliant every time he ran the ball
i held my breath i think physically and
i think it's kind of been
borne out i mean you know they're
michael vicking this kid
he's he's not built to take uh
nfl hits and even though he's got that
mad
speed i guess he didn't get out of
bounds quick enough no many times even
the president was commenting on that
talking about how he needed to get down
and he needed to get out
and you know but for instance
thanksgiving
two years ago in dallas yes when he went
back to
texas and just crushed
dallas in front of the whole country to
see that
had to be something that you
had a sight for sore eyes and think
maybe he can do that again
certainly with the weapons that he does
have at his disposal if he stays healthy
yeah i actually i think it was the new
orleans game last year that
it's a brilliant game yeah that's where
i went oh my god he actually is the real
deal making these
uh great throws under duress
so um you know i i was a doubter but i
was open for it uh he proved
me wrong and then i you know now we're
just dealing with
the kind of the physical the thing and
can he come back
from that we'll see you know i know we
will see so
rfk that's your that's your upbringing
you're going into that stadium
you know i was sonny jurgensen billy
kilmer and then some young kid named
thiesman thighs they got him returning
punts for george allen you know
right i saw a game in the in rfk
uh two rows from the front
of the uh the upper deck two rows in
yeah in the end zone
and i had to get up and look over
to see what was going on in the back of
the end zone
and when the skins would score i
literally felt the place shake you would
watch
yeah watch it bounce yeah yeah you felt
the age
you felt the whole history of it yeah i
think it wasn't like the smallest
stadium in the nfl there for well and
now they play in the largest
i mean prior to jerry jones coming in
and and building his jones mahal
in dallas which i've been to which is
yes pretty impressive and we were
talking about
uh the super bowl between the steelers
and the uh cardinals before you were you
were there
yeah you were at that game yep so what
is your rooting interest when you go to
a game like that
do you don't have one or you just go you
know what i do i i underdog
i'm i am a sucker for underdogs that's
why i i
have no connection i have no idea why i
wanted to see detroit
in the super bowl and i want to see
cleveland because they've never been
sure i want him there yeah well you're
speaking for everybody in detroit and
cleveland
yeah that's for sure they would like to
see that too yeah but first i want to
see my redskins
what do you think is going to happen
first detroit cleveland or the redskins
getting into the super bowl
i think cleveland if you if you had the
three
yeah you like it huh i i'm a hoyer fan
i i think uh and i and i think johnny
manziel's great
i just think uh cooler heads prevailed
and they said you know this kid was
whatever he was 3-0 4-0
yep last year before he got blown up he
was 3-0 there you go and i thought
you know he he kind of deserved it he
proved it and you know i guess in
training camp he did well enough to
keep the job he did and to get johnny
man's i mean when you draft johnny
manziel you sort of want to use him
and then lebron comes to town and
suddenly you want to use your star
player and instead they go with this kid
with a re-constructed knee and he's done
pretty well for himself i agree that's a
good story
i like his story yeah what is a white
bird
in a blizzard about christopher maloney
ah it is a drama
a mystery um kind of fantastical
much like the redskins season so far
without the fantastical
um if somebody gets hurt in this
somebody gets
someone disappears much like the
redskins wins
ah oh no i love the red sky i know
you're letting your smile be your
umbrella right now i love you
i know you do um
yeah and it stars uh shailene woodley
who's red hot
she is it she's a lovely person and uh
even better
better person great actress and ava
green who plays my wife and you know
it's about the dysfunction of a family
and uh
alcoholism and mental stresses and
depression lots of stuff going on
a lot of laughs we no this is the clip
as we're about to show
will show a white uh white bird and a
blizzard october 24th let's roll
laughs you seem very you can have that
mustache by the way
is that right i saved it so so you
didn't you didn't grow it for the role
very impressive very very impressive i
did not that so
yeah that is intense i got that i got
some intensity from that from that
clip right there and it's it's your look
seemed inspired if i may
from uh kyle orton right now i don't
know if you've seen what kyle orton
looks like right now
have you seen that have you seen what
kyle orton the the buffalo bills
starting quarterback looks like right
now yeah all right take here take it
there we go what do you think
does that look like you in the in the
film oh my god
i could be starting quarterback with the
buffalo bill would you like to
yes we can work we can make dreams
happen on this program
i still got my i got my arm i can throw
i can on a line i can zip that ball 25
how were you in high school
how were you in high school uh vr
quarterback uh
i was i was i didn't have a great arm
but i made up with it by being slow
so you got heart uh that's what it can't
teach what beats inside christopher
you are i had the will to win
that's all i had was the name what was
the name of your high school uh saint
stephen saints the saints
and were you were you chris maloney back
in the day or now yeah
yeah your chris maloney quarterback
christopher p maloney quarterback
chris maloney yeah and before we let you
go what is on your shirt give a pop to
your uh okay yeah this is
uh my good friend maynard who has the
lead singer of tool
okay uh a perfect circle and here he is
leading his other
band called the pussifer okay there you
have it there you have it
all right we appreciate you coming on
here pleasure
thank you i'd love to have you back
welcome anytime you want to promote
anything you just want to come in here
and promote your skins which you fight
for old people
soon someday soon you fight for old dc
christopher maloney good to see you
thank you go see white bird in a
blizzard october
24th in a theater near you
the rich eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern
on audience